today we're talking about the increasing
amount of woke advertising you see all
around you this isn't just a razor this
is a razor that is challenging gender
stereotypes and taking on the evils of
toxic masculinity this isn't just a shoe
it's colin kaepernick show that he
exclusively uses to kneel in and this
isn't just liquid disappointment no this
is the drink that supermodel kendall
Jenner uses when she is out there
protesting some generic issue
while medium-sized corporations like Ben
& Jerry's in Patagonia have used woke
advertising pretty much as long as
they've been around it seems that even
the biggest companies are beginning to
dip their toes into the woke world which
is surprising since large companies with
a diverse customer base usually avoid
controversy like the plague
but now are purposely courting it with
woke advertising why are companies doing
this stepping into social issues when
all they do is sell razors to understand
as you first have to know the rules of
advertising have been flipped upside
down with new media in the days of TV
land you paid for an ad spot got a set
number of viewers who were watching at
the time and that was that but on the
internet you can go viral in fact one of
Gillette's biggest competitors Dollar
Shave Club was launched to success like
that that video got them 26 million
views now think about how big of a
change that is suddenly your ad reach
isn't limited by how much money you have
if you can get people to share your ad
can go worldwide without you spending a
penny and this is about more than
YouTube videos all of social media can
be used and while some companies are
moving to social media with the same
tactics that used in TV land some are
using this chance to pivot because
growing an audience isn't so much about
Hawking your product anymore as it is
about being funny or relatable it's only
after you pull them in that you sell to
them today brands don't just want to run
ads before a funny YouTube video they
want to be the funny YouTube video they
want to create a movie with one of
YouTube's biggest creators as an ad yes
but mostly just as a sharable piece of
good branded content and they don't want
some generic actor telling you how good
their product is they want me to create
personal branded messaging for you
because when I say
how good how good this is you know you
can trust me all of this is to create a
seamless integration between the ad and
what you're already interested in we can
define the shift like this brands used
to interrupt your regularly scheduled
programming nowadays brands want to be a
part of your regularly scheduled
programming it's the only way to survive
because the old model just doesn't work
anymore we are conditioned to tune out
interruptions on our attention the
second you're watching something and a
commercial comes on you grab this
everybody loves to talk about live
sports commercials being this great
thing I don't understand why people
don't look at the most basic data which
is the singular biggest lift in Twitter
activity is during global sporting
events when they go to commercials and
this is where woke ads come into our
story with brands realizing you're
exposed to hundreds of ads every day
everyone's trying to find a way to be
the one you talk about they want to find
a way to stop you from going to your
phone during the break or skipping the
ad they want you to have a conversation
about them and there are many ways to do
this with a funny ad or a clever ad but
another way is to take a strong stance
in a pre-existing public conversation to
step into a social movement and take a
side because then rather than
interrupting the brand can join the
conversation even if that conversation
is more like a screaming match
advertisers want attention by any means
necessary
not to mention controversy creates views
shares and comments from people half the
audience is bashing the ad and the other
half bashes them for overreacting to the
ad and on it goes until you have twenty
eight million views and Counting now of
course the real question is is the price
of this attention worth it is echoing
half your market segment worth angering
the other half will Millennials and ijen
resonate with these social justice
messages enough to change razors we
haven't seen enough data on this to know
how the long-term and short-term effects
of woke advertising affect sales so we
have to wait and see
but what we know for certain is that
companies are desperate to cut through
the noise of other
Kaiser's for some this means roasting
people on Twitter for others it means
staking out a social issue and defining
yourself around it now as a consumer I
personally find the idea of
socio-political raisers to be both
invasive and a little too black mirror
ish I don't like that it mixes a
socially inert product like a razor with
a social movement it brings in a
political conversation into yet another
corner of our lives but from a business
perspective it has undeniable potential
social issues have become increasingly
important for businesses as they look
for new ways to join the conversation
rather than interrupted and while large
established companies have mainly
avoided making social and political
stances we're beginning to see large
companies willing to take that risk
knowing that they need to adapt to the
changing market because as long as they
can get your attention they can get you
talking they can sell to you
[Music]
took me out of the cream
thanks for watching that video um
subscribe if you haven't already hit the
bell because we've got some amazing
videos coming on the trending tab if
you've seen Susan wood the CEO of
YouTube's most recent post we've got
some response to that if you want to see
that if you want to make sure you see
that make sure you hit the bell the
other thing is is that look this isn't
exactly the most original take effort
when I have written it if you could tell
some of the the references were dated
it's because I wrote it early on this
year it's actually coming out around
like May so it was like a four month
period between when I had originally
written it and when like it's actually
coming out so in that time a lot of
people have done takes on this that are
very similar to my own I hadn't seen
those at the time of writing not that it
really matters but I typically don't
like to do stuff that's already been
done and there are people like a bomber
guy and Sarah Z who have terrific takes
on this and I just wanted to acknowledge
those takes exist I'm not I'm not trying
to pretend no one else has talked about
this before so I'll leave their videos
in the description as well as a few
other takes on this if you're interested
some of them are political I don't have
political takes on this but if you want
to see those kind of things the links
are down below the last thing I want to
say is not everything is a cynical
calculation by these companies while it
may come off that way and while when you
deconstruct it it can sound like brands
are cynically you know pursuing social
justice messages to get an audience
that's not exactly true if you go watch
a link vist below as well mark
pritchards add color conference you will
see he's the like lead advertising guy
for P&G the biggest advertiser in the
world he believes in all of this stuff I
mean he believes in the message that
he's selling my point in saying that Oh
taking this very business he look at why
people would use woek advertising is
just to say regardless of mark
pritchards intentions and other
advertisers intentions for good or for
ill what is for sure is that woke
advertising is a force that people are
figuring out what to do with and it
should be interesting if we see more
mark pritchards in the future because
that business strategy works or we see
them fall away because it doesn't work
but he has an interesting talk and so
linked that as well Oh
last last thing if you're interested in
advertising and you're interested in in
like marketing anything cut like that
go watch gary vaynerchuk's keynote at
Wieden and Kennedy one of the big
commercial advertising groups
he has a great take that I think is
essential for the modern era of
advertising so I'll link to blows sorry
you have I've given you a lot of
homework but if you're interested in
these topics it's a good place to start
thanks for watching